foreign
comes from Beth in North Carolina my 18
year old has forty thousand dollars in
stocks that was given to him by a family
member to pay for college should he pull
money from them to pay for each semester
or pull money from them and pay each
year in full is one option better than
another or does it not matter if he
pulls from them how does he figure out
how much he'll pay in taxes each year he
cashes out stocks it's an interesting
question I'll let you speak to the tax
part but I'll quickly cover the
financial aid part one of the biggest
questions I would have is is the
financial aid eligible because this
money could definitely impact that a lot
of people don't realize how assets can
impact the EFC equation which is your
expected family contribution so if you
are a student your assets are factored
in at 20 percent whenever they're
calculating your financial aid and if
that's income it's factored at 50 so by
pulling that money in if he's still
applying for the FAFSA it could be
counted as income in a future Financial
need equation therefore it could reduce
his eligibility for future financial aid
so that's a factor that a lot of people
don't consider when they're looking at
so what would be his best strategy in
that case
well he may not want to spend it at all
until the end of college if he can find
another way to go to school debt free he
may want to just leave that money
invested if he can get scholarships if
he can pay for it because right now it's
a student asset so student assets are
factored at 20 percent so that's eight
thousand dollars versus at the income if
he pulls it out is income is factored in
at 20 at 50 percent yeah but if he pulls
out uh if there's forty thousand dollars
he pulls out ten thousand dollars it's
five thousand dollars not eight but the
thing is is it just depends on what his
ultimate EFC is if he's a high need
Student that could not come out of the
running for different um five thousand
dollars could if it increases it's EFC
significantly so
um well and it's just that money could
be if he can get a scholarship instead I
mean it could be better to left leave
that money saved because if he's got a
zero if he can work and get scholarships
and not touch it that's going to be the
best for the equation yes especially for
future financial aid but eight thousand
dollars to still count against him just
because he's got it on the books twenty
percent of 40. yeah I mean it's still
gonna it's still gonna count so it's
just important to look at how your
income and assets are going to affect
you especially as a student so if it's a
parental asset it's only factored in at
5.64 so parental assets have a lot less
of a ding on the financial aid equation
what the crap do they get 5.64 I know
this is bureaucrats right it's just 5.64
is the exact number of actual oh my God
but it's just it's a conversation to
have a lot of conversation to have but
at the end of the day no in no case are
we saying use debt to keep from messing
with this you use this money to avoid
debt at the end of the day if you have
to even if it messes up something else
go get scholarships work leave the money
alone is the best for the formula right
but if you um if if the formula is if
you don't have access to anything use
the money pay cash for college as you go
now go ahead it's also important that
this this family member they put it in
the student's name perhaps they could
have put it in the parents 529 therefore
it would have been a parental asset but
if they put that in a brokerage account
in stocks in the student's name then
that's just a different Factor so if
you're a family member wanting to give
student a student money for college talk
to the parent because you could put it
in the parents 529 and then that'll
affect the FAFSA differently yeah so
just be strategic about that because
I've talked to countless families who
didn't really know how that fact unless
you're just going to give them enough
pay for college and that's it right
that's fantastic just gonna pay for
college forty thousand pays for the Hulk
schools and that's different but it
won't yeah so in most cases anyway yeah
I wrote about it in my second book how
to graduate debt free just how parents
and students can look at their income
and assets to make sure they're doing it
the most strategic way in informed way
so that they don't accidentally ding
themselves on the FAFSA just not knowing
yeah not your answer your tax question
is this your basis for tax calculation
is in other words the equivalent of what
you paid for it it would be your basis
normally but with a gift your basis is
the value of the stock at the time he
received it
so it's worth forty thousand dollars
today uh let's say that it was worth
thirty thousand dollars when he received
it
and it's gone up to 40. he only pays tax
on the gain over what it was worth when
he got it
that's all okay and so he needs to
figure out what the value was at the
time he received the gift of the
portfolio and there's probably something
with a broker the broker would probably
do that one phone call one email all
right and so uh whoever the financial
advisor that's helping you with this is
can probably do that and then you're
going to pay he's going to pay taxes at
the capital gains rate of 15 percent
over what he paid for or what it was
worth at the time he received it and so
in my example if he cashed out the whole
stinking thing and it was worth 30 when
he got it it's worth 40 now he has a ten
thousand dollar taxable event at 15
percent the taxes are fifteen hundred
bucks and so it's not it's not bad so
your your basis in a gift is the value
at the time no wait a minute
that's on Estates I just did that wrong
all the CPAs out there are throwing
Rotten Tomatoes at the radio right now I
screwed that up no the basis is what the
guy that gave it to him paid for it
it's worse
well the family member what they paid
for it is the basis on a gift
it's not he did not inherit it it's not
an estate it stepped up basis in an
inheritance but on this in this case you
guys can all send me hate mail on
Twitter and everything else you do
anyway but yeah I screwed that up I
almost screwed it up I fixed it yeah you
got it caught it halfway through my as I
stumbled across the line and fumbled the
ball and missed the Super Bowl but
anyway yeah the uh uh yeah so yeah
that's it you you have to find out what
the family member paid for this set of
stocks that he gave to your
18 year old and that let's say and
that's probably a lot less
well you got a lot of taxes here yeah
and to quickly go back to the income so
if they took out that forty thousand
dollars
um in one single calendar year and it's
factored in at 50 of their income then
that reduces their aid eligibility in
future years by 50 so that's twenty
thousand all the future years as well
not just that year next year over next
year the following year okay yeah so
it's actually a twenty thousand dollar
ding so one thing they could have done
would have been to cash it out when he
was a senior in high school
and put it into any Esa or junior year
because now it's prior prior yeah yeah
if you go away to Junior that'd be even
better but yeah if it was that long ago
and and that way it doesn't affect your
formula and it gets it out of single
stocks and put it in something else
right where it's not as volatile uh
because I don't know what this portfolio
looks like so there's a lot going on
here uh the bottom line is We're not
gonna look a gift horse in the mouth
haha this is a gift and so uh there's
lots of good things about getting forty
thousand dollars that I can count that
or beat any kind of equations for uh
financial aid or beat a little bit of uh
capital gains taxes so it's a wonderful
wonderful gift well just have those
conversations because it could be a
simple conversation sophomore year could
save you you know four thousand eight
thousand dollars in the long run and
that's worth it just simply by having
that knowledge and if you moved it into
a 529 in a mutual fund it going up in
value of no taxes from that point
forward so you would limit the taxes and
you would have limited the damage to the
thing if you'd have moved it ahead of
time so there we go now we got a good
strategy should the sophomore year
remove it then